so I so that doesn't mean that you know
you you have your premier and that's it
all the efforts go away no you're still
going to you know within release and
whether you're looking for distribution
or not you're still going to be keeping
up that audience engagement often if you
are looking for a distributor they're
gonna start looking to see how many
people are talking about this you know
how many people know about this they
start looking at numbers they start
doing Google searches to see how many
hits are we getting of people that are
mentioning this it's very easy tools to
use to find out is there any bodies on
this you know does anybody know anything
about this if they can find a pretty
engaged audience a community of people
who are anxiously awaiting you become so
much more attractive as a bi than
somebody who's done nothing has nothing
out there waiting waiting waiting for
somebody to pick them up and they're
going left you know we might we might
not we might and we won't give you
anything upfront and we'll see what we
do they're not gonna work it the same as
you so their amount of audience
engagement is going to be less you would
still have to be doing that even even
with a distributor but if you choose to
do the route where some part of direct
distribution is is part of your plan and
I really hope filmmakers are doing that
if you're doing all this work to get an
audience why are you gonna turn that
money and those those people over to
this middleman who's not going to do
that work but who is going to be
collecting money what they should be
doing is expanding your audience beyond
what you have done and they do it with
money more than they do it with labor I
assume what you're gonna be working with
mainly is labor and not a lot of money
so that's why I say start really tight
and core because that it's easiest to
reach when you have a little bit of
money but you're still going to be doing
efforts you know throughout the release
and and new opportunities will come you
will find new tools online and ways to
use them sometimes you'll hear about
them from the audience that you've been
talking to you know media opportunities
will come to you one example of that is
when I was doing this Joffrey release we
didn't use Pinterest from the start it
was kind of just coming up when or
getting popular when we were in release
already and I looked at it I go well we
have all these photo assets and there's
kinds of stuff on the web to do with
ballet and things to do with the Joffrey
so I opened up like a boards for
different themes and put pictures there
well we got asked back in the fall
before we before it played on PBS by a
woman who's writing a book for
Entrepreneur Magazine about Pinterest
for business using Pinterest for
business and she wanted to know if she
could use the joffrey account as an
example in her book which doesn't reach
the ballet audience in particular but it
definitely expands you know your your
coverage your reach beyond that and
those are things that you can't
anticipate when you're doing this you
know it's these are opportunities that
just come along and if you have already
laid the groundwork for it you can take
advantage of it so there are lots of you
know these kind of things that it'll you
know still be beyond that six months it
could be another year that you're still
working the audience and you're
subtracting sales then you actually have
the what the effort is going to go into
driving traffic and getting money sure
do you find that we've that we see
enough success stories with sort of like
one-off films you know like if the
filmmaker puts in all this effort and
it's mainly just for one film is that
really enough time is this enough
audience building are we going to see it
do we see enough success stories or is
this really something where it needs to
be more than one film it needs to be one
film led into the next before we really
start to see the fruits of all this
effort and labor um well yes I hope that
most filmmakers that we know and who are
doing this are doing it because they're
they have more than one film in them
sometimes I think that the ones that
don't is because they had too high of
expectations they they didn't have they
hadn't managed their expectations out of
what was possible for their first film
not everybody's gonna be beast of the
southern wild you know that's not the
model that is the anomaly it's you know
more likely that the first couple of
films you make are gonna be very small
they're gonna have very limited success
you have to be very careful with a
budget when you're doing that but expect
I would rather see you expect to be
small and grow bigger than expect a huge
explosion and it doesn't
and because then it's money lost
disappointment disillusionment
self-doubt all those things that crush
you crush you and make you fearful of
doing anything in the future it's much
better to start small expect less hope
to get more but expect less and build on
that everything you're doing is building
for your next thing building into the
future keeping those people that are
with you and transitioning them not
letting everything fall to the ground
wait several years try to get it going
again that's so hard that's that's so
much wasted effort in the first thing
that you did and now you've got to start
it again it becomes really daunting do I
think we hear enough case studies no
because most of the mainstream media
that covers the film industry's not
covering these kind of stories so that's
why it's great we have film courage you
know that we have filmmaker magazine in
some ways individual people's blogs that
we can read about these films that we
probably wouldn't have heard of
especially if we weren't directly in the
target audience but for sure that
they're not playing in the local cinema
they're not gonna get it broadcast deal
and play widely but that doesn't mean
that they haven't had some form of
success or something that they can share
as an experience that people can learn
from and those things that when you're
teaching somebody they remember about
you and they see out you know you in the
future so I think that it's the job of
all of us to try to work together in
supporting one another that we are not
all in competition with each other that
the that the name of the game is not
greed and taking from other people in
order to make ourselves bigger that the
really the promise of the Internet is
being able to make connections and
connect lots of people and be supportive
in general you know they you support
them they support you and we all grow we
all have the potential for success when
we think that way it's a very radical
thing I'm saying I know it sounds very
new-age and love in or whatever
totally not Hollywood I'm cool with not
being totally Hollywood but but I know
that it works I know that you can grow
and succeed by helping other people
so I encourage people to just do that
mindset shift a little bit that it not
so selfish and more self giving will
prevail that you will see success out of
it
you